in 2012 a little-known tv and movie
performer landed the starring role in
the year's most watched global event
this is the queen's stuntman
well good evening with more than seven
years in the planning the eyes of the
world tonight here on london with the
2012 games finally opening
let's get the thoughts of our guests
here tonight sky ceremonial commentator
alastair bruce who's been here my name
is alistair bruce
the london olympics began on friday the
27th of july 2012. any minute we're
going to see the start with the cauldron
lighting and the games can begin and
these games that night i was on the
balcony of the thistle hotel i think it
was called right beside the tower bridge
and it was the most electric evening
and the opening ceremony
right now at the olympic park in
stratford sky news didn't have
permission to be in the amphitheaters
itself so we were watching much of what
was fed out on a screen very much like
everybody was at home we know they've
been rumors about a bond type film
that's been made for the opening
ceremony so we will keep our eyes on
that bridge so suddenly in the whole
performance the cameras take us to
buckingham palace
and james bond went into the building
i had absolutely no idea that this stunt
involving the queen
and the james bond story was going to
take place from the queen to celebrities
and i thought they can't have got a
stunt double that looks that good and
that like the queen
my name's gary connery
i was asked to be the stunt double to
her royal highness queen elizabeth ii
james bond was chaperoning if you like
the queen to the olympics
and the idea being that we arrive by a
helicopter over the stadium
the two of us jump out free fall
momentarily open our parachutes and uh
he delivers her to the opening ceremony
what essentially this was was a stunt by
the queen i mean this was something that
could go spectacularly right
or wrong
for everyone involved
[Music]
i grew up in
bengio which is a small town just
outside hartford in hertfordshire
whenever people ask me how did i become
a stuntman i always give the flippant
answer of i've bunked off school lots
but in the uk there is
a procedure to get on what's known as
the stunt register
it's not for the faint-hearted
i fly wing suits i base jump i kayak i
crash cars i get hit by cars
i get set on fire
i've doubled for gary oldman on the
batman films
john hurt in indiana jones
anything that you see stuntwise on
television
i'm probably in there at some point
[Music]
around october time 2011
i got a phone call from a friend of mine
who is a rigger in the tv and film world
and he said to me gary are you available
to go to
stratford east london for a meeting and
at the time he didn't tell me
what that was
so i arrived at stratford three mills
studios
about half an hour had gone by and there
was a crackle over the radio
dan is on his way to your meeting now
and everybody's sort of suddenly
adjusted themselves
you know shoulders back chest out kind
of thing and i'm thinking to myself
crikey who is this danny
danny boyle walks in the door
he takes one look at me says gary
hello danny what are you doing here
i knew danny from the film the beach the
leonardo dicaprio movie the beach
when danny boyle agreed to direct the
opening ceremony of the london olympics
his plan was to showcase the best of
british culture
pillars of life like the monarchy
the nhs
even james bond the iconic british spy
it was decided that the centerpiece of
the show would take the form of james
bond and the queen who was of course set
to open the olympics anyway
both of whom
would parachute into the stadium from a
helicopter
for this illusion to work
the queen would need to play herself
alongside daniel craig as james bond
in this mini movie both would be seen to
travel from buckingham palace to
stratford via helicopter
this segment would be broadcast to the
world so it was made to look as though
the action was unfolding in real time
but at the same time a second helicopter
carrying stunt doubles for the queen and
james bond would hover out of sight near
the stadium
when it came to the critical moment the
jump itself
the action would cut to the stunt
doubles leaping
into the arena
the whole thing
was top secret
he
asked me whether it was possible
and
i said you know
falling and opening a parachute and
landing that's that's a given that can
be done
but it just depends what else is within
that arena
what essentially this was was a stunt by
the queen
she herself had decided to do this and
she was participating in it along with
an a-list hollywood actor daniel craig
who was basically james bond this figure
of what is known around the world as the
great british character in film
so i was doubling for the queen and mark
sutton was doubling as james bond
we were using base jumping equipment so
it's essentially jumping from static
objects with a parachute
and it's generally much lower altitude
than one would skydive
it's a different sort of equipment set
up
but they are very good and they work
but also human error can pack the
parachute wrong so
it's not like working in tv and film
where generally you can call cut and go
and do it again this was a one-off
one attempt
in front of you know a worldwide
audience to get it right and so that's
where the sort of level of fear and the
focus and the concentration was at its
utmost
a very good evening after more than
seven years in the planning the eyes of
the world here on london tonight the
2012 games finally opened and boy
so we
got into the uh the helicopter at a
bridge
airfield which is just north of the
stadium i guess by maybe
six or seven miles
so obviously when one is doubling
somebody else there's a whole
costume and makeup team that try to make
you look as much like that person as
possible
angela kelly has been a personal
assistant to the queen for some years
and she has
always known precisely how to dress the
queen well and there will have been a
lot of discussion between angela kelly
and ultimately the stunt man who was
gary and you know gary would have had to
spend time with angela and make sure
that what she made for him
mirrored exactly what the queen was
going to be wearing herself in order to
create the illusion and bring it to as
much a sense of reality as possible
so i had the queen's dressmaker she
measured me up to have a dress made that
could also incorporate the straps of the
parachute
so i was wearing flat shoes i think i
had
some tights on looked very good
this peach salmon dress which was
beautiful
a big costume
ring a big diamond
i had one of the queen's personal
handbags apparently so i'm told
i was wearing a wig
and of course my union flag parachute
i was hugely surprised that the queen
had decided to do this and i expect the
queen would have wanted to know what the
risks were to her reputation and profile
[Music]
if
mark and i had decided we can't do this
even to the second
there was a button that they press in
the control room which goes to
another pre-recorded piece to basically
end the sequence
and i don't know what that was
maybe they pre-recorded a helicopter
then banking away and landing
and then the queen gets revealed again
i have no
idea let's get the thoughts of our
guests here tonight sky ceremonial
commentator alastair bruce
sometimes an event can really bring the
whole country together and over 70 days
by passing this very simple
we took off about 40 minutes before we
would do overhead we know there'd been
rumors about a bond type film that's
been made for the opening ceremony so
the flight from the airfield to the
stadium was actually very short
because we weren't that far north of
where the stadium was but they did want
us up
early so that we were ready and in place
and prepared
our jump would time in with that
pre-recorded stuff
so suddenly in the whole performance the
cameras take us to buckingham palace
and we went up the stairs and james bond
went into the building
and then he went into the room and there
she was it was undeniably the queen
this is a pre-record
but it's made to look like it's
happening in real time
from that moment the whole brilliance of
the concept started to grasp us
of course she goes with the corgis
and we only saw her feet going into the
helicopter we didn't know where it was
going
we were hovering outside the stadium
they were playing the
pre-record on the screens within the
stadium
everyone watching to see if the uk can
put on a show to wow the world even
james bond
we could see those screens from in the
helicopter
and then the helicopter took off
and then it passed certain significant
points
on london's skyline
then it went underneath the great
traverse arch of the tower bridge
and this certainly is danny boyle the
film director at work here knowing what
works visually oh definitely and i think
that throughout we got the call a minute
overhead and absolutely everything ramps
up again at that point
it was dark everywhere the lighting was
phenomenal
people they had these paddles that they
held every seat had a sort of lighting
paddle and so they could hold that up
and
you know the computer systems would then
light all those paddles up
it was just phenomenal
so we were at 750 feet
the towers of the stadium are 210 feet
so that gave us
540 feet to jump out
free fall
open our parachutes
spiral a little bit and then get away
from the stadium to then be able to land
just outside the stadium so this was
going to happen we were going to jump
into the opening ceremony of the
olympics
for all of our rehearsals we'd had a
countdown from 10
so that it timed out with the pre-record
and of course this amazing moment when
the door opened and james bond said are
you ready your majesty
i remember turning and saying to mark
we're going
under sort of a gasp of everybody
we could hear um the bond theme tune
being played out
you know
that kicked in
your awarenesses are so heightened you
wouldn't hear
the blades
[Applause]
and they're literally feet above you but
you'd hear the bells on the toes of
fairies dancing 700 feet below
i remember the parachute opening that's
always a good feeling
[Applause]
i remember then spiraling around to my
left and looking back and seeing mark
and we sort of caught one another's eye
and we were screaming at each other it
was great
then it was all about basically clearing
the
sides of the stadium to get out
over
the towers and all of the cables and
lines and everything that was there
and because of the wind direction we had
to approach over the water and then get
to land on quite a narrow bridge
it made much more sense for us to land
outside of the stadium which also meant
then it was easier to reveal the queen
coming into the stadium
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the best of british
that was tremendous because the rumors
have been flying around here for several
hours that something like that was going
to happen well they always have a list
of when by the time i came out into the
stadium and sat with my wife
essentially it was already over
from a spectacle perspective but then
the athletes were walking around for
them to have their moments too
it's nice to remain anonymous
this for me
fantastic as it was it was still just
another job
the best job i've ever had a hasten to
add but it was another job
for the united kingdom that was one of
the great worldwide events that we were
able to host
and i suppose the palace were delighted
because in the end it went well there
was a risk but the risk was worth taking
because it was worth taking for the
success of the london olympics 2012
danny boyle pulled it off and it led to
a great fortnight of fabulous athletics
and all forms of sport
the queen hasn't
hasn't taken it upon herself to invite
me around for tea and cakes yet but i do
know where she lives so i might go and
knock on her door at some point
[Music]
in 2013 mark sutton who played james
bond's double on the night of the
opening ceremony died following a
parachute stunt accident involving a
wingsuit in switzerland
gary connery continues to work in the
industry
the queen's stuntman was recorded by tom
gillespie writing production and sound
design by rob mulher
for more information go to sky news dot
com forward slash storycast 21.
next time
the so-called year 2000 computer bug has
generated fears that anything from
nuclear missiles to interbank trading
systems could fail when 1999 turns into
the year 2000
[Music]